today and last night that is in on the
hands and brantley is hit
by a pitch
so he's grabbing that right wrist man oh
man you can hear some of the oakland
faithful cheering the guy getting hit
again but michael braley got a pitch up
and in from a left-hander trying to keep
that front shoulder closed ends up
taking it off that wrist hopefully just
a little bit of a bruise and maybe a
shock to the system hopefully he'll be
fine the rest of the day because he has
been swinging the bat so well
brantley is going to stay in the game
tucker down to the count one and two
tucker hits it hard and that's a base
hit to right field brantley will trot
home diaz will be held up at third kyle
tucker has come through with four rbis
his last three times at the plate and he
gives the astros a one nothing lead
and here getting opportunities early in
the season and taking advantage of him
with the infield pulled in
it allows you to sneak some of these
line drives through the infield past
these infielders tony kemp at second
base
only had a step in a dive to try and get
to that ball and could not lance
mccullers on the mound he's got that
fastball it's a two-seamer
he got him again there you go that
chapman a little aggressive on three and
one and then on the 3-2 pitch mccullers
strikes him out on the breaking that's
what he goes to that's his bread and
butter over the years
and fortunately he gets chapman
struggling a little bit to pick up that
pitch out of the hand and gets him to
chase so he has the swing and miss
ability
payoff pitch again here it is
it's hit hard based at center field
cannon rounds third straws throw to the
plate away off line in the 80s have tied
it moreland with an rbi hit
knocks in a run after a very good at-bat
smart at that too because got the
breaking ball again instead of
trying to pull it maybe cueing the ball
off the end of the bat the previous
pitch and the team just kind of settled
in a little bit look at the shift they
checked the hip to the right side he did
not hit it hard there
single could have been extra bases in
the left center but the a's able to get
on the board thanks to canna walking
olsen walking and now mitch morgan
coming through big time picking up his
third baseman
swaying a foul tip caught by maldonado
big strikeout for lance
three two
over for strike three frozen with the
breaking ball and the inning draws to a
close
altuve sends one to left field that'll
be down for a hit in to score jordan
alvarez everybody else moving up a base
the astros retake the lead it's 2-1 on
altuve's rbi single
keep it going altuve again in that
lead-off spot with the bottom part of
the order getting guys on base it allows
them the rbi opportunity but irving is
missing up in the zone with some of
these pitches and the astros are getting
to them for some of these base hits
one two
strike three call frozen with the
breaking ball and the inning is over
mccullers needs 12 pitches to get
through the second after a 33 pitch
first
swaying and a miss got him with the
curveball down and in mitch moreland
strikes out five strikeouts for
mccullers
laborious effort to go out there and get
mitch moreland but does with that power
breaking ball down and in much better
than the 3-2 pitch earlier in the game
that mitch moreland shot back up the
middle for an rbi base hit but this one
was beautifully placed down and in
frozen
on the breaking ball on the outside
corner that was all over the plate and
lance picks up strikeout number six of a
work ethic standpoint showing these kids
how to go about their business on a
day-in day-out basis
marcus
replacement is elvis anders what a plug
right on cue
that was a sensational play i don't care
who's running i didn't think he had any
shot full extension dive toward left
field comes up thrower you called the
kite lay out one time for the elvis get
up and play a tune baby right on over to
only with a big stretch
and for elvis to be able to get up pop
up make the throw knows he's got about a
12 foot target over there to help him
out
and he likes it
[Applause]
swing and a miss one two three three
pitch strikeout for lance mccullars
that's now seven strikeouts one away
in the fourth
good morning good afternoon good night
fastball in breaking ball away and then
just back one up out of the plate you
know
we'll now face jordan alvarez
jordan sends one in the air to center
field well hit going all the way back to
the wall that ball is gone
the big man jordan alvarez hits one to
left center field a three-run shot
and the astros take a 5-1 lead there we
go
we got liftoff you're don alvarez again
showing some of that prodigious pop
that is not an easy pitch to get
sharply on the ground but altuve is
there to correa and they turn the double
play
lance mccullers jr gets the double play
to get through the fifth inning and it
is 5-1 astros
big spot here bottom half of the eighth
inning with the bases loaded and one out
the new pitcher is brooks rayleigh
swinging a miss big strikeout for brooks
raleigh getting the pinch hitter jed
lowry swinging for out number two
cut her inside cut her outside cut her
back inside tough to cover both sides of
the plate tried to pull the hands in
but unsuccessful israeli snuck that
cutter past him
big swing and miss for that out base is
loaded two outs in the bottom of the
eighth inning
ball sent in the air to center field
pretty well hit straw back he's near the
track he makes the play in front of the
wall for the final out
chad pinder making a bid to tie the game
it is 5-1 after eight astros lead
a one pitch chas mccormick gets into one
deep to left him this pulls off the wall
mark team malzado will score jose altuve
to third chaz mccormick an rbi double i
think the strike was fouled off as diaz
will shoot one into left field that will
score one run mccormick being held up
bounces past the catcher garcia
and sliding in head first is mccormick
with the run in practice and bring it to
the game this ball lofted deep enough
for a sac fly pinder all the way in
front of the warning track makes the
catch i led miss diaz can
we saw him flip the switch in the
postseason last year we're seeing him
flip the switch here early on in oakland
bidding that chas mccormick will put the
ball away for the final out he had his
first major league hit today
the astros have scored 25 runs in 10
games last year and 26 runs in three
games this year against the oakland a's
they have won the series they will go
for a sweep tomorrow today's final score
9-1